my secret is my secret is okay what's
this thing on ya my secret is that
everyday I'm afraid to be exactly who I
am I just started dating my best friend
of three years and I really hate it and
I don't know how to get out because I
love him so much that I don't want to
hurt him
[Music]
my secret is I feel like I've never been
accepted by either one of my races I was
homeless when I was in elementary school
and we couldn't find a home for months
and we lived in a motel 8 and my mom was
a gambler and she gambled our money our
rent money away and I couldn't pay for
lunch at school and I haven't wanted to
tell anybody that
my secret is I hope that my parents are
proud of me because I always thought I
was such a disappointment
I really want my parents to be proud of
me all right well my secret is my father
was an alcoholic we were pushed around
from house to house kicked to the curb
by police officers not having really a
good home
it felt like my family wasn't always
there for me and just wanted me there to
do what they wanted but not what I
wanted
so my hardest thing was I had to leave
home I left at a very young age but I'm
happy that I found someone that stuck by
me and still is and I couldn't ask for
anything else
my only motivation of going to college
is to prove my father wrong he told me
that I end up like my mother and end up
as a stripper my secret is finally
admitting that I have problems with
mental health and really addressing it
especially in the asian-american
community
it was kind of hard coming to terms of
that with my family especially my
parents so yeah that's my secret did he
do do do do do do do I one time came
across a drowning Falcon in a pond and I
tried to save it but it ended up dying
and sometimes I feel really guilty about
it because I think that it probably
could have died peacefully and I think
that I prolonged its life unnecessarily
[Music]
this is the first year I have can
officially say that I truly love myself
and don't pay anything about myself and
am confident in my own body
I have a secret tattoo that's his family
but my family doesn't know about it in
tenth grade I may have slightly hit a
car and left but pretended to leave a
note because I knew people were watching
me I'm 22 and I've never had a man I've
been spending a lot of time shopping for
the perfect pair of women's cashmere
pants because they're just more
comfortable than men's cashmere pants my
secret is I have a lot of Netflix and
chill buddies I have an unhealthy
addiction to Harry Potter
hey I'm a RA
and I like one of my residents
my secret is my longest and best
relationship started because I wanted to
confirm whether or not I'm asexual and I
am I'm still in this relationship and I
hadn't talked to him about it it's been
about three years so we'll see I
[Music]
recently found out that my father is not
my biological father I was conceived
using donor sperm as we're both of my
sisters we recently learned this
information and send out our DNA tests
and I found out that I have two half
siblings out there and I probably have
more and I'm excited to find out more
about it but it's something that is
still very difficult to come to terms
my mother was pregnant with me the
doctors told my parents that I was going
to be born with Down syndrome and my
parents were convinced that that wasn't
the truth actually weeks before my mom
actually gave birth to me
the doctors would call her and would
tell her every single day for weeks on
end to have an abortion so I almost
wasn't born my family is very religious
my dad went to the temple I'm just kind
of praying about like what they should
do and and he said that when he came
back he received inspiration that what
the doctors are viewing as Down syndrome
was actually some sort of bright
intelligence everyone and actually in
the church was waiting for me to be
either having the abortion or have down
syndrome because they didn't believe my
parents and my parents won't have the
baby and 18 years later Here I am and I
don't have any Down syndrome and I don't
know if I have any sort of bright
intelligence or whatever but I know that
I'm alive today and I'm grateful to my
parents for keeping me
[Music]
my dreams involve entertainment and
performing I'm gonna stage a lot but
honestly I'm very anxious and extremely
self-conscious
whenever I'm involved with
[Music]
I have finally moved on from my past
relationship and it makes me really
really happy
my secret is I am the happiest when I am
alone it's easy to be happy when the
people around you're happy but I'm
learning it's really important to be
happy alone my secret is that growing up
in Cameroon we were very close my
brother and I but over the years we have
grown our separate ways we're not very
close anymore and I wish you were very
close because I want to have a buddy to
talk to you sometimes and it's just
tough because I'm so different I guess
but I'm working on it that's my secret
hey it's gonna be okay when I was in
first grade the kid who sat next to me
everybody would always kind of like pick
on him because he was kind of gross and
kind of mean everyone and one time I
wasn't feeling good I remember I farted
in class and it was pretty loud but
because everyone thought he was gross
they all just assumed it was him so
everyone was they into this kid and like
making fun of him and I never told
anyone that it was me and that's all my
grandfather started a second family that
we've never met and every time I meet
someone with my last name I wonder if
I'm related to them I lost the ring that
my mom gave me recently and she doesn't
know sorry mom I love you no one really
knows me they don't know that I'm
multifaceted that I love it venture that
I'm excited about life even though I'm
past 50 I don't think it's over I don't
think this is all that there is for me I
think there's much more I'm excited
about it but I can't share this with the
people that I that I deal with on a
daily basis because they'll think I'm
crazy or I'm weird or I'm you know
what's wrong with you you've already
lived half your life you should have
done it by now
but I have it and there's much more to
see and do for me thank you
I never thought how much traveling could
help me grow as a person like I've never
been away from home for more than a week
or two and I've been on the road for
like two months now and you don't always
get what you want with traveling but you
got something fun out of it all the time
because you mean nice people like you
yeah having fun and go do it
people are complete up this even when
they don't need to be we're all going
through so much and it's really really
sad to have to see other people putting
other people down or other people having
to drag other people in order to advance
when there's so many opportunities it's
such a crowd mentality that I kind of
wish that it would just end there's so
much room for each and every one of us
that to whoever is hearing this right
now literally there's a space for you
and any part that you want to get into
so as much as you can and help the next
person out and hope that that happens
for you as well and if it doesn't it's
all good you move on but literally
there's no need to be and other people
you never know what they're going
through even if even if someone's and lt
you it doesn't matter you don't know
their story you don't know what happened
to them five minutes ago five years ago
five seconds ago it really doesn't
matter be nice that's a
[Music]
hey guys I just wanna let you know real
quick that I made some new sweaters and
I'm doing a giveaway on my Instagram so
find me on there and follow the
instructions on my most recent post to
enter other than that I just really want
to thank you guys I want to thank all
the new subscribers I've gone and the
subscribers that have been with me for a
while you guys don't understand how much
fun I have making these videos and it's
so cool to have a bigger audience to
share them with so thank you for that
and I think that's pretty much it I'll
see you guys next week